That's it!
We're gonna do some trick shots
With the rackets we made
In the DIY episode
If you missed that video
Go and check it out here!
Good chops!
This rubber side
You can get some spin with it
It's just super slow
I'm surprised
How well you can...
Hit with that
A normal
But really, really slow rubber!
Let's try the forehand around the net
What!?
That was fairly easy!
Alright
Let's try and play with the Pongfinity net
Come on!
It went in!
Another one
Go and get one of these
From www.pongfinity.store
Ok, so I'll try to challenge Emil
With a blade without rubbers
Let's see how it goes!
Straight down on your side
How many lucky points can there be?
I think there was only three!
Ok that was good!
I'm not even gonna say sorry
Victory against the Sensei!
Yeah it was a good match
I think that was one of the best matches we have ever played
Yeah I think so too!
Okay Miikka, you ready for today's training?
Yeah what are we doing?
Sit-ups
Down on the floor!
Okay! Now!
Move move!
Yes, yes
All the way down, all the way down
Better, better!
All the way down!
Come on!
Faster!
Emil decides the tempo!
Tell him to go faster!
Faster tempo Emil
Good, good
Five more
Use your muscles
Good
That's it, that's it!
And back, yes!
Good workout!
Yeah thanks
Alright, so the next challenge
Is to hit the world's longest
Table tennis smash
What's the record?
I actually checked
And I didn't find any current record, so
So we're gonna make the record?
We're gonna make the record
It's seventeen and a half
From this wall, to that wall
17.5 meters (57.4 ft)
Let's see if we can
Go over the wall
To the other side
That would be pretty good
Yeah it would be
Miikka goes first
Thank you
Good luck
Okay, first shot
That was really bad
I can do better with my left hand!
Okay
That's better
That was a bit better
What's it saying?
That's fifteen
Fifteen!
A bit over 15 (meters) = 49.2 ft
Yess!
I'm happy with that
That was a lot better than the first one
Try to improve the same for the last one
I can feel it in my hand
Yeah that's good!
Nice!
That's 16.10 meters! (=52.8ft)
16.10 meters
That's good
First attempt
Do your best
I will
That's a bit too high
Too high
It has to be like
A bit lower and then
It's hard to get your feet here
Yeah it is
14.6 (meters) = 47.9 ft
Well that was like one meter better than your first
That was
That was one meter better than my first one
Good start
Yeah, looking good
It was better
Much better
15,3 meters (50.2 ft)
There you go, last one
Come on, now everything into the third!
No, it's not good
It was longer!
Was it?
-Yes
It was better
That was
15,6 meters (51.2 ft)
I'm still in the lead
I have a feeling that Otto's gonna...
Going to go past us though
Okay you guys ready?
Yeah
Oh no!
He beat us with the first try!
I guess...
Not really a surprise?
Within 1,2 meters all (3.9 ft)
Yeah it's quite evenly spread out
I think we should try and break this
17,5 meters (57.4 ft)
This was Otto's first try
It's like half a meter
We'll try and
At least break our own records
Yeah
Okay Otto!
Let's go!
Oh, that's good!
It's 5 centimeters away from the edge
Come on Otto
You can do it
Last try!
Pressure is high!
That's it, that's it!
Yeah!
Come on!
Nice one!
17.65 meters (57.9 ft), the unofficial world record
Held by the Sensei!
No, the really official!
Yeah this is very official!
I want to see it if someone can do it
If you can do better, send us the clip
Yeah
And then I'll try to beat that...
I gave it my everything!
Yeah, nice try!
I think you can get one more
So that was it for today
Good job Otto on making the unofficial world record!
Thanks
And there's still some time before Christmas
So if you haven't got a present yet
Go and check out: www.pongfinity.store
Our Christmas campaign
Is still going on
Until next time!
You missed it!